[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat les beaux jours
reviennent et avec une envie de sortir
de s'aérer faire du tourisme pourquoi
pas encore faut-il muscler les
infrastructures évinoise la région
annoncé une enveloppe de 12 millions
d'euros de la vallée de chevreuse sur
trois ans pour dynamiser les centres
villes et leur attractivité touristique
est ce suffisant pour renforcer l'offre
touristique du département faut-il
chercher des sources de financement
ailleurs des sites touristiques publics
sont une bien armé pour faire face à la
concurrence des autres départements pour
débattre de ces questions j'accueille
autour de moi deux professionnels du
tourisme
olga gattaz directrice de la mission
tourisme au conseil les départementales
mais également ambroise graffin
directeur de l'espace rambouillet
bonsoir à vous et merci d'accepter avoir
accepté cette invitation alors le
tourisme dans les yvelines ces 2,7
millions de touristes essentiellement
des franciliens même si le nombre
d'emplois et d'établissements
touristiques ont augmenté ces dernières
années le département fait office de
belle endormie
comment expliquer comment expliquer ce
frein pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
réveiller notamment le potentiel
touristique du département qui veut
commencer je peux commencer dans le bon
soir il y a
plusieurs
on peut dire qu'il ya plusieurs réponses
à cette question tout d'abord nous
sommes très proches de paris d'un côté
c'est un inconvénient de l'autre côté
c'est un avantage
pourquoi cet inconvénient c'est un
inconvénient puisque
les gens qui vont venir sur paris de
l'étranger par exemple vont venir
visiter des sites
mythique de paris qu'on autorise fl
montmartre faire une balade
sur une croisière et c est finalement
trois jours c'est pas énorme pour
visiter paris
je vous faudra une bonne semaine pour
profiter de tous les dieux des musées
etc et donc finalement on reste dans
l'ombre de paris d'accord donc les
éviers sont phagocytés par
l'attractivité de paris ont beaucoup du
mal à se démarquer de sa pourtant je
croyais que le point fort des et
viennent s'y donne notamment les espaces
verts parce que là c'est à dire que ce
sont neuf autres espaces verts n'est pas
suffisamment forte pour justement lutter
contre paris l'image n'est pas
suffisamment développé je vais peut-être
et laisser la parole spécialistes
justement de l'espace national des
forêts féminin général le tourisme à
venir chercher quelque chose d'unique un
peu de temps à et finalement c'est on
nous n'avons pas développé cette image à
l'international pour le moment d'accord
déficience d'imagés est ce que les
personnes les franciliens et même des
étrangers connaissent justement la
richesse forestière des yvelines
bonsoir je vais rebondir un petit peu
sur votre première question déjà
question d'attractivité c'est vrai que
pour la partie forestière j'aime quand
tu n'es plus là dessus il se pose assez
rapidement des questions d'accès
d'accessibilité alors quand on veut
aller en forêt l'accès le plus facile
c'est en voiture mais après à proximité
on va dire la l'agglomération parisienne
il ya aussi les embouteillages qui vont
avec
donc il ya ces questions et peuvent se
poser pour les pour les visiteurs mais
globalement si on regarde le nombre de
visiteurs en forêt il est en constante
augmentation
en ile de france depuis une trentaine
d'années donc il ya une tendance quand
même qui est développement 2-2 de ses
visites mais qui est beaucoup le fait de
citoyen fin d'habitants régionaux et
alors enfin en revenir à votre question
sur l'attractivité j'irai pour des
touristes
c'est vrai que l'être un touriste et je
parle tous les spots aux étrangers à la
région là pour la partie nature c'est
vrai qu'il ya encore du travail à faire
en termes de d'expliquer je dirais la
facilité d'accès et pour conclure si on
regarde une situation comparable
de l'autre côté l'aggravation de
l'agglomération parisienne
parme sur le massif de fontainebleau
c'est quelque chose qui est plus je
dirais mise en valeur et les chiffres le
montrent tous en fait il ya beaucoup
plus de visiteurs touristique sur ce
massif là d'accord donc il ya une
déficience de notoriété en tout cas sur
tout ce qui est tourisme dans les
yvelines s'est orientée questions
d'accès si on pensait à fontaine au loup
il ya une ligne ferroviaire en fait avec
un arrêt en fait en pratique en pleine
forêt d'accord pour toi rambouillet ça
va quand même accessible aussi en
transport en commun il ya quand même
d'être à leur tour rambouillet oui mais
après je vous refais au marché une
petite heure pour aller en forêt quoi
d'accord et si vous et à vos enfants
qu'il faut re marché encore en forêt ça
fait une addition qui est un peu la
balade est trop longue
d'accord donc c'est à dire le problème
des yvelines c'est qu'elle est trop
proche de paris même temps pas
suffisamment éloigné pour éviter des ces
inconvénients les bouchons le transport
c'est bien ça et justement quelles sont
les solutions pour remédier à cette
paranoïa des transports pour essayer
d'attirer et les autres franciliens il y
aussi les personnes dont les régions aux
abords je pense que au delà de dax et on
va dire
c'est aujourd'hui même pour le touriste
brésilien s'est plus dépaysant interne
psycho psychologies com est un homme
d'image de sortir de l'île de france est
d'aller vers la loire ou en fait vers
leurs ovaires normandie que de rester
sur l'île de france
il y à aussi
la question de renouvellement d'offres
est ce qu a encore une fois sur
versailles sur notre territoire nous
avons le château de versailles qui est
le monument le plus visité au monde et
[Musique]
donc l'idée c'est de profiter de
d
de cet avantage pour attirer les
touristes
les tons juste par le renouvellement
d'offres notamment donc aujourd'hui à
part à part les transports il faut qu'
il faut une remise en question en terme
d'accueil de la clientèle internationale
il faut
aussi parlé en fait d'une expérience
client pour que au delà de publicité
visibilité sur le site internet dans la
presse et c'est l'expérience client
parole aujourd'hui vous elle vous avez
les réseaux sociaux comme tripadvisor il
ya des bus qui sont visitées il faut que
par renouvellement d'offres et services
il ya une attirance et les touristes
parlent autour d'eux d'une expérience
exceptionnelle qu'ils ont eue et du coup
si vous voyez sur le territoire nous
avons beaucoup de choses à faire je peux
pas dire que c'est pas mis en valeur
mais il faut d'une part construire une
image à donner une image d'attractivité
et de reconnaissance d'un territoire
touristique ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et ça se fait d'une part par
l'attractivité des sites mais d'autres
pas aussi par l'attractivité du
territoire et c'est quelque chose qui
est très très lié donc et je pense
aujourd'hui est un donné qu' on est
justement ainsi près de paris et si loin
en même temps il faut
profiter de cette proximité aujourd'hui
justement il ne faut pas changer de
modèle c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent
ce j'en crois les chiffres c'est
essentiellement des séjours de deux
familles qui vient ici qui héberge chez
qui sont hébergées chez d'autres
personnes que cela ne profite pas à
l'hôtellerie et ils dépensent environ 76
euros par personne et par jour est ce
qu'aujourd'hui justement ne faut pas
attirer une autre cliente est justement
il faut viser sur russie on parle d'une
clientèle internationale mais aussi
française qui va venir visiter paris il
vend actuellement
la région c'est 2
de se repositionner et de dire ok on
n'est justement pas très loin de paris
en fait à proximité vous pouvez voir sa
salle au fond culturel il ya beaucoup
d'artistes qu'ils ont cherché
l'inspiration etc
il ya beaucoup de châteaux il ya des
vignes royal il ya des villes impériales
et il y a
les espaces naturels qui sont
magnifiques beaucoup de randonnées des
vélos route qui passe par par le
département ont péri de tout ça c'est
autant de pistes justement pour ces de
renforcer à travailler vite et ensuite à
ce que les sites ce public on l'est
vraiment les moyens de mettre des
politiques et ambitieuse pour pouvoir
justement attirer davantage de personnes
notamment si je regarde les différentes
dotations d'état qui baisse d'année en
année à ce que vous êtes
oui on fait tout est de 8 de la tête
donc c'est à dire vous êtes profondément
impactés justement vous dresse pas
laurent bouhnik moment fait ça veut pas
dire ça et bien par rapport au contexte
budgétaire public compliqué
on doit faire avec effectivement mais
par rapport à ça je reste comme
optimiste
c'est à dire qu'on a toujours un minimum
de moyens et qui permet notamment de
renouveler de une offre et avoir de la
créativité et je vais prendre un exemple
concret pour rebondir sur ce qu dizier
là dessus nous on a on a développé une
des prestations en fait de team building
nature et passa les chantiers nature
depuis trois quatre ans c'est à dire que
vous vous dirigez vers un public
d'entreprise ça vient voilà d'entreprise
ou à ça peut être deux groupes d'adultes
ont fait aussi un peu un peu un peu à
peu près des scolaires l'idée générale
en fait c'est que on transmet un message
fort sur la protection de
l'environnement à travers la réalisation
d'une bonne action ensemble
après on l'a pas mal développée pour les
entreprises parce que il ya une demande
là dessus et ça marche bien et bien en
trois quatre ans je dirais avec peu de
moyens ne serait-ce que les forêts en
stock
donc on a et puis un retour d'expérience
aujourd'hui on a un catalogue une
quinzaine de chantiers et on fait 50
journées comme ça par encore toc c'est à
dire que pour vous l'écotourisme ça
fonctionne et ça attire vaut d
entreprise à clairement clairement après
je suis pas le seul à le dire un
clermont on voit
au niveau national même international
cette tendance de créer de la cohésion
l'équipe sur des soies des thèmes de
nature soit 17 et thème solidaires aussi
c'est quelque chose qui développe de
plus en plus haut niveau de l'entreprise
et hélas si on si on regarde la densité
d'entreprises dans les yvelines
et là la densité
du des massifs forestiers il ya encore
pas mal de potentiel quoi d'accord si je
crois une information qui sentit dans le
parisien il semblerait notamment que le
conseil départemental s'apprêterait à
faire une délégation de service public
pour château de la madeleine
est-ce que c'est pas une façon déjà est
ce que c'est bien vrai ce qu'on pouvait
confirmer cette information est ensuite
n'est ce pas un moyen justement de se
donner de l'air en faisant entrer des
acteurs privés pour pouvoir dynamiser le
tourisme dans les éoliennes alors c'est
une cellule c'est une information
effectivement que vous avez qui devrait
donc aujourd'hui le département dans un
premier temps à chercher des moyens pour
investir pour restaurer le monument
donc c'est à vous c'est coûteux et ça
prend ça prend du temps parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de règlements à respecter donc
les travaux sa prise du temps donc de
confirmer la possibilité de le faire
donc les travaux ont lieu entre 2018 et
donc une fois
le château est mis un an et fectivement
on va c'est pas la compétence du
département la gestion de ce type de
site
on va
cherchez donc délégation de surf public
donc il y aura un appel à candidatures
d'accord l'objectif c'est contrecarrer
ou attirer aussi la même clientèle que
provins éventuellement on voir une autre
clientèle parce que dans les yvelines et
une forte thématique médiévale également
donc
l'idée c'est vraiment développer cette
thématique
encore une fois ça s'inscrit dans la
stratégie du département de d'une part
devait le peu de vlp l'offre et d'autre
part aussi de positionner le département
comme une destination touristique via
les thématiques spécifiques et le
médiéval en fait partie d'accord donc
développé renouveler les offres c'est
justement de contrecarrer cette ses
proches si loin de paris est ce que par
exemple
malheureusement le château de versailles
n'a pas pu nous envoyer un responsable
autour de cette table mais ils sont en
train de développer de vrais de voilà
ils sont en train de faire des travaux
notamment dans leur parc pour créer un
hôtel de luxe un peu comme un modèle
qu'on peut voir dans la péninsule
ibérique avec notamment les paladins
relations et les poussent à s' est ce
que ce genre de tourisme de luxe est une
option pour vous et notamment dans le
cas de l'écotourisme oui clairement
vous avez des projets qui vont dans ce
sens à rambouillet oui alors déjà on a
des
des prestations faut qu'on propose déjà
aujourd'hui avec des soirées un peu vip
sur l'observation des grands animaux
avec un bon repas à côté après nous on
reste je dirais on s'arrête à une
prestation toute la partie hébergement
pour l'instant
elle est parfaite sur le site néanmoins
on a des partenariats on a un camping
nature confort utopia juste à côté et on
fait maintenant assez régulièrement des
je tiens d des offres complètes avec eux
comme ça d on a accueilli la dernière
des conseils d'administration qui vont
rester une soirée assisté une soirée au
brame par exemple espace rambouillet ils
vont dormir dans les chalets confort en
pleine nature
utopia et puis le lendemain il repart tu
peux rester une journée séminaire
c'est à dire vous ne pouvez pas faire ça
sent le secteur privé aujourd'hui vous
ne vous avez vous êtes obligés
aujourd'hui on fait ça comme ça après et
nous on va lancer une étude stratégique
sur notre site cette année tu il n'est
pas du tout enfin écarté compartir de
l'hébergement effectivement sur le site
en construction
parce que si vous regardez vous à la
cité l'exemple de versailles mais nous
avons des exemples plus proches comme
tout ce qui est partie aux logiques parc
animalier
c'est une tendance tendance nette les
grands parcs animaliers maintenant fond
de l'hébergement sur leur site voire de
l'hébergement je dirais exceptionnel
exceptionnel avec une grande baie vitrée
le matin on peut vous réveiller on y ait
des réactions ça sera les serres où les
sangliers ou la forêt ça correspond à 2
un dépaysement l'expérience là je reste
part résolument optimiste pour les
yvelines où il ya un potentiel avec ce
quoi c'est un 50 km de paris vous avez
un dépaysement nature trade accepté de
participer à cette émission quant à vous
je vous invite à revoir cette émission
sur notre site internet passionna grêle
de soirée la semaine prochaine
[Musique]